第1回！お家でかくれんぼ選手権ーーーー！！！
いえーい
とゆうわけで、僕んち！
もう住所ばれてるんでいいんですけど
3階立てです！
[まさき　拍手]
拍手ではないかｗ
3回建てなんで、隠れる場所がかなり多いし
部屋数も、1.2.3.4.5個ぐらいあって廊下とかもあるし 、お風呂場もあるんで
あの・・多分普通の家より全然多いし
複雑な構造になっています。
ネットでググれば直ぐ見つかります。
なので今日ちょっと4人のメンバーで、かくれんぼしていきたいと思います。
じゃんけんで負けた人が見つける人。勝った人3人が隠れる人で
・・・あの・・本気でやって下さい。
どんな手を使ってでも隠れればいいので。
場所は部屋から出ちゃだめです。
い（規制（　＾ω＾））辺りならアリ。
外壁も全然ありだと思います
スパイダーマンみたいにねｗ
はじめん家だなぐらいの場所だったら
（規制）っ家っぽかったら
セーフにしましょう。
で、制限時間が
10分の間に見つけてください。
罰ゲームはなんか…テキトーに…
海に飛び込んでもらいましょう！！！
(●｀･ω･)ゞ＜ok！
負けが鬼で
さいっしょはグー、じゃんけんぽん！
じゃんけんぽん！
じゃ俺が探して、
３人見つけられないと、まさきの負けね
あー２人見つかっても、1人見つからないと
隠れましょう！！！
みんな本気で場所を探しております。
それは強い。
じゃあたくみさんそこで
ここにします
素晴らしい。
支えようか？
肩のっていいよ
いい？
はい。いくよ？はい。いくよ？はい。
あ、汚ねえ、ヤバッ
ここちょｗ
大丈夫？
大丈夫。
ねぇ、怖い
いった（痛い）いった（痛い）
怖い
痛い痛い痛
わぁーやばいよー
あんた優勝だろ？
あんた凄いよ…
STARTしまーす
よし…
いたーｗ
あーびっくりしたー
えー？なんで？
何でここ開けるの？
ここはいない
え？待って待って待って
ちょっと焦るなぁ
ここは　流石に
えー？
ちょっとなんかこれ、わざとらしいな…
え？
え？マジどこどこどこ？
やばいやばい
さすがに…
ここも
ぃないけど
え、やばいやばいやばいｗ
え？
あぁ
こういうとこ？
いないよねぇ
え？
へえ゛え゛え゛～
あ～～ぅ
いない。いない。
え？うそだぁ
これ結構、まずいんじゃない？
やばいやばいやばい
え？やばいやばいｗ
やばい！？
あ…これ　あんまり…
え゛？
下？
やばい々々々々々々々々々々々々々
え？やばいやばい
あと二人でしょ？！
ん　なんかこの辺いるとは思わないんだけどな…
え？やばくない？
怖いなぁ
はじめさん大きいから絶対…分かると思ったんだけど
えええええ゛？
え？違う違うやばいやばいやばいやばいやばい
あと、二分ちょい
え？嘘嘘嘘？
あと二分三十五
え？嘘？
えぇぇぇ？
あっあ！わかっ
ひやあ゛う゛
いたーー
バレたーバレた
え？待って待って%@*$#&./wwww
えー一番おおｋi@*%$#"?~あるよ～
やーあと一分！！
あ゛～違う
へぇ？へぇ？何で一番おっきい人が分かんないんだろう？？
違うよー゛ｗｗｗ
え？え？え？え？
やばくない？
え？いやいやyyy'%&$#"?>{@*+\
いないよ～～（震え声）
もっと上だぁ！
え？待ってバスタブの裏？
え？へへへへへ？ｗｗｗｗ
はははは
そこ？
残念だったなｗｗ まさきww
そこ家？
ブクブクブク
ひゃひゃひゃひゃｗｗｗｗｗ